Lumos maxima
yesterday a wizard and in New York with
a case
became full of magical creatures
then unfortunately some have escaped
I was hoping just a smidge mr. Scamander
it was like calm like a ghost I saw its
eyes shining white eyes and it throws
down underground
the strange things going on all over the
city people behind this are not like you
and me there's a hidden society it goes
back centuries
yesterday wizard entered New York with a
case
a case full of magical creatures and
unfortunately some have escaped tini
Hubert meant home that's mr. Scamander
he's lost something I'm going to help
him fine we're gonna recapture my
creatures before they get hurt they're
currently in alien terrain surrounded by
millions of the most vicious creatures
on the planet humans
magical beasts are terrorizing no mages
and no matches are afraid they attack
contain this phone it'll mean boar why
would I have to wear something like this
because your skull is acceptable to
breakage under immense force
don't panic that there's absolutely
nothing to worry about
I wanna be a wizard
my heroes are always people who feel
themselves to be set apart stigmatized
or other dots at the heart of most of
what I write
and it's certainly at my heart in this
movie fantastic beasts and where to find
them was a textbook that Harry Potter
used at school while I was writing
Potter I became quite interested in Newt
Scamander so I knew quite a lot about
Newt he's been traveling the world
studying magical creatures
he calls himself a Magister ologist
first trip to America yes
that fix new creatures blares in this
magical case you open it up you can go
down it's an amazing space this feels
more at home with creatures than he does
with human beings come on give me a paw
Newt walks into a society he doesn't
really understand this is grounded do
you know anything about the Wizarding
community in America I know that you
have rather backward stores about
relations with no magic people you don't
mean to befriend them you can't marry
them which seems wildly of certainly him
and then Jacob accidentally opens in its
case full of magical creatures hey mr.
English guy I think your egg is hatching
so new to gets embroiled in this
adventure you started a little bit more
like a beer
it's something that has implications for
the whole Wizarding World
interesting man mr. Scamander just like
your suitcase I think there's much more
to you than meets the eye
kicked out of Hogwarts danger human life
for the beasts
at one of your teachers argued strongly
against your expulsion
and why and what makes Albus Dumbledore
so fond of you mr. Smith
first trip to America yes muskie that
fix anything edible in there I'm a nut
knife any livestock welcome to New York
no human could do this thing's capable
of